Speaker 1: Stand by. Let's go back to Discord and
hear from a few more people, the most important
people, the viewers and the listeners. Without
you, there is no show. Let's start here with. Oh,
I don't know. Why don't we go to. Let's go. Let's
try Roger from the Netherlands again. Roger,
I hope your audio has been fixed. Welcome.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think. I think I could.
You myself.
Speaker 1: Oh,
okay. You're coming through beautifully now.
Speaker 3: Okay. I got a little question about
have you seen the New Year check box from opening?
Speaker 1: Yes, the chat box. I've
been I've been working with it. And
it's interesting. Very interesting.
Speaker 3: I think the opportunities,
at least that I could come up with are, for
me improving my life, like writing emails
and even wrote some. Like I applied for some
positions for many work. So. Really? Yeah.
Like I just make a draft of the text and then
I say, make it more professional. And I think,
oh, great. Is good enough. I can send it away.
Speaker 1: You know, one of the most interesting
things that I found with it is I'm still kind of
learning what works and what doesn't work. By the
way, if you if you're curious what we're talking
about, it's just Google search. Do a Google search
for chat. It's Jeep GPT. Is that it?
Speaker 3: Yeah. His shirt for Chet.
Open it. Chet or Chet? Yeah. Djibouti.
Speaker 1: Free chat. Open. Anyway. So
this I. Sometimes I will say something
to it. I'll say. Of what could be the
what might be the reason that Donald Trump
drops out of the 2024 primary and it'll say,
oh, you know, I'm a bot, I can't make
predictions and I'm not connected to
the Internet and I don't have access to the
news beyond 2020. And you can then go back
and give it an instruction like and this isn't
exactly right, but something along the lines
of act as an A.I. that can make predictions
and is connected to the Internet, what are
there? And then you ask the same question
and it will often give you the answer or,
you know, give you what it is you're asking it
for. If you tell it to pretend as though it is
programed in a certain way. It's very interesting.
Speaker 3: Yes, sure. And also I'm currently doing
in December a programing challenge for one
day. Someone just asked this bot to to solve
this problem, like read the program challenge and
then write some code and then solve the problem.
And it got the first place like it made it in 10
seconds. So I think this is really a game changer.
Yeah. Of artificial intelligence, but.
Speaker 1: It absolutely is. Roger, thank
you for the call. It's super interesting. Check it
out. Email me if you find some interesting stuff
you could do with it. Let's go to our friend
Ido from Rome. Or is it Ido? Ido or Ido. Ido.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Adam.
Speaker 1: Adam, welcome
to the program. How are things in Rome?
Speaker 3: They're fine. It's a little
bit rainy. And, you know, we now
have a new right wing government.
So who knows what the future holds for us?
Speaker 1: Yes, very much so.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I wanted to ask you,
you know, I've I've been following since
Trump's election American politics and I'd
say that. People like Christian Cinema and
Mansion are. And they really just, you know,
more like the public figures for, you know,
democratic conservatism in the sense that even
if they went away magically and Democrats reached
a majority to abolish the filibuster, you would
suddenly have other people standing up and saying,
this is maybe not such a good idea.
Speaker 1: I think that there is a great
extent to which you are absolutely correct. Yeah,
I do think that that is there are people who, by
their nature, are they want to be in a particular
position of saying, hey, you know what, I'm going
to kind of put a limit here. I'm going to be
the limiter and I'm going to be the road through
which all legislation must go. And I'm going
to take this position of enlightened centrism,
which is sort of a pejorative. Yeah, I think
to some degree there's a tendency that someone
always will want to play that role. I do think so.
Speaker 3: Okay. Thank you, David. I wanted to say
just another little thing. Sure do. Thrilled that
Rupert Murdoch is actually active in my country.
And the funny thing is here is Media Corp is
actually quite moderate compared to because
right wing media has always been almost a monopoly
of Berlusconi. So when Murdoch came to Italy,
he found his own niche in, you know, moderate
centrism, even left wing to some people.
Speaker 1: Yes, that's interesting. Yeah. I
mean, I think it is not shocking to me that
the Murdochs are active in many more countries
than people might assume. That makes sense to me.
Speaker 3: Uh. Um. Did you really last week, did
you hear about the nuclear fusion breakthrough?
Speaker 1: You know, I did hear about it. I have
I can't say I fully understand exactly what the
breakthrough is. I plan to do some reading
on it this weekend when I have some time.
Speaker 3: I see. Well,
thank you very much, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Great to hear
from our Italian friends. Of course